normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Tik
talk will scrub videos of anti-israel
genzer fawning over Bin Laden's vial
2002 letter to America because it
clearly violates our rules on supporting
any form of terrorism I want to show you
this image in this image can you switch
over Serge it says ticktockers uh are
now justifying this from Libs of Tik Tok
the 911 attacks and praising Bin Laden
because he was just the resistance this
man in in one of his videos it it says
2011 me finding out we got him and he's
cheering then it switches to this
reading his letter to America knowing he
was right full stop the point Tik Tock
is doing what we have seen social media
companies do quite a bit of they are
creating a trend and these people have
not actually read Bin Laden's letter not
even a single word of it and I know for
a fact I think any sane person can see
that what they're doing is instead oh
this guy got a million views by saying
that let me make the same video and get
a million views there's there's
definitely a lot of that I don't I don't
think it's a lot there no way woke
leftists read a letter saying ban
homosexuality and then said he was right
so you're telling me that you don't
believe in woke leftists ability to
contradict themselves and like drop of a
DA say I'm saying that some of these
posts that are prominent come from
Muslim activists who are saying look he
was right and they do you see the video
where uh was it was billboard Chris and
the antifa guide goes up to two Muslim
women and says he's trying to stop kids
from being trans and and they're like we
agree what happens then is because
people are getting millions of views
these other young people are like I want
to get millions of views and just make a
a fake video claiming they read the
letter they did not I'm not denying that
that I'm sure there are people who are
doing that but I'm just but I'm just
making the point they can cont they can
contradict themselves but I will not but
I mean in the most blatant way they they
can contct themselves no I mean i' I've
seen over and again where the woke
leftist can literally sit here and say
like um they go there's no such thing as
gender and also I knew I was in the
wrong gender from the moment I was born
cuz it's in my brain and these are the
completely contradictory ideas we had L
from the surfs on the show who said you
can get abortion whenever you want then
he said but but a woman can't do meth
because it intentionally kills the baby
right we've seen these things and
everybody loved that clip but I do not
believe you can take a statement ban
homosexuality put it in front of any
leftist and say would you agree with
this I think if they would not agree
with it well look I the the the issue
here always is and I've I've been
struggling with this myself over the
last uh say month or whatever is that I
think when there is uh when there is a
reasonable point to be made and then
it's put into the hands of left Wingers
to make that reasonable point they will
make it in the worst way possible um so
I think that what's going on obviously
this has to do with the context of
what's happening with Israel and and
Gaza right now right like that's that's
the part of the reason why this is going
so 16-year-olds chanting from the river
to the sea is why they're saying Bin
Laden was right they don't know anything
about what they're talking I come listen
I'm not defending leftwing 16-year-olds
they're going to say a lot of stupid
things but this is the point I think
that but I think what the what what the
point should be so I'm I'm with you
completely leftwing 16-year-olds are
stupid that's not that's my my point is
it is not just 16-year-olds we have
37-year-old Millennials who are
indoctrinated in the exact same way they
no also yes no sure sure but listen
these are people in the intelligence
agencies how old is vindman these are
people who are at the CIA who are
removing Donald Trump from the
presidency because they believe this
crackpot BS I mean I think I think the
people I think the people in the
intelligence agencies even the ones who
are removing uh or trying to remove
Donald Trump are much more on board with
Israel than against Israel uh but I
would say this look I think the kernel
of Truth here and what a lot of these
guys just are trying to get at but do a
horrible job of of getting at it is that
look in Ben Laden's letter to America
obviously he's an islamist and he's
saying all types of crazy things that a
lot of us don't agree with well Sheamus
may be mostly but the rest of us don't
agree with that uh but there are stated
grievances in this letter you have to
admit okay he probably has a legit
grievance here you understand why this
would be why this would be fertile
ground for Recruitment and why almost
any people would probably resent this if
this was Happ let me read the first one
as for the first question why are we
fighting and opposing you the answer is
very simple number one with a bullet
because you attacked us and continue to
attack us that's the first thing he says
so like no no no no no full stop full
stop I I am I I'm sorry dude I I I
reject this outright you can't just read
a sentence I can read I've read the
whole thing Tim I know exactly what he
say so you need to understand what
attack us means and he outlines very
clearly in the entire second half
attacking us means stopping Sharia Islam
from taking over the world yes he also
includes 1.5 million kids that that
starve in Iraq because of the sanction
regime you can't discount that either my
point is it's like a guy saying I I am I
am attacking you because you kicked my
dog and we're like wow you kicked his
dog why and he goes because I was trying
to to eat it and you're like well wait
wait hold on this so what's happening is
you got a lot of these leftists and Glen
Greenwall did this too Bin Laden was mad
about US foreign policy Bin Laden was
mad about US foreign policy imposing it
it's a western Viewpoint and preventing
Islam it's all in his well look okay
again there's no question he's a radical
islamist and that's all that's that's uh
all throughout the letter you can see
that there but I think that the issue is
that so these left wiers take it in this
Direction that's like well he was right
and you're like no of course that's not
the conclusion the conclusion is he was
an insane mad man who's obviously like
an e he's obviously an evil figure
there's no getting around that the point
is that obviously within this islamist
rhetoric there are also these grievances
of and look the that you have attacked
us that you have bases in our holy land
that you uh you prop up brutal dictators
in our region that you support the
Israelis who are are are have ethnically
CLE uh cleanse the Palestinians that you
uh and then of course the sanctions
campaign against the Iraqis and all the
kids who died now I'm not saying
obviously his wishes his wishes are that
they would be under Sharia law and and
Muslim control but it's still here's the
thing right when it since uh from 911
and the years these have slowed down a
little bit but for at least 15 years
afterward the FBI did all of these um
you know sting operations what they what
are really entament operations where
they claim we foiled another terrorist
plot but then you find out that they
created the whole thing every time they
did it every time they did it go look at
how they recruited the person listen
they never read them the Quran they
always said how do you feel about us
foreign policy in the Muslim world the
point shouldn't be that Osama bin Lan's
a good guy the point should be that this
is why he was able to recruit people who
were willing to go blow themselves up
and sacrif let me point this out when
Glenn Greenwald let me pull up Glen
greenal tweet says his three main
grievances are us sanctions on Iraq that
killed the hundreds of thousands of
Iraqi children two US support for
Israeli violence and three US troops on
sacred Saudi land that is this is what
pisses me off that is I'll tell you what
that is that's black lives matter that
is Michael Brown that is BLM saying they
shot and killed Michael Brown that's why
we're mad that's why we're rioting and
then you go well hold on there a minute
Michael Brown robbed a liquor store and
then attacked the cop okay so if if
you're really saying you're mad that he
was shot what you're actually saying is
your intention is to be able to freely
and willfully Rob and and attack cops
and guess what it's actually happening
now so you're saying it's lying through
a mission not including the full context
of the when we get when we get people
like Glenn Greenwald coming out and
saying well look Bin Laden said they
were mad about us for he was mad about
foreign policy no no no no no no BLM
comes out and says police are attacking
us so we want to abolish the police
we're now three years past the summer of
love and what's happening they're they
just released two guys in New York who
mercilessly beat a cop without bail we
had a woman who was just killed and I I
think it was in I'm not sure where it
was because the guy got released without
bail everything they said they said
these cops are killing us so we need to
stop this they weren't actually mad cops
were killing them they were mad that
cops were stopping criminals from doing
extremist things okay so I I I just
don't I don't think the comparison is
perfect I get your point on the BL stuff
that okay sure go so you read the first
line you attack us want me to read you
the first line of what he defines read
the thing you got to I'm not going to
read the whole thing on the show cuz
it's long but he says uh in the first
section under your supervision consent
and orders the governments of our
countries which act as your agents
attack us on a daily basis one these
governments prevent our people from
establishing Islamic Sharia using
violence and lies to do so okay two they
humiliate us three so when you ask him
what does it mean to be attacked on a
daily basis he is not saying I can't
believe that you're shooting at us he's
saying we want Sharia he goes on to say
the whole second half number two Tim
what he's clarifying there is that
you're you're toppling the leadership
that they want you're basically you're
in they they're asking aomy I disagree
with them but if they want autonomy they
want if they want sovereignty then they
can have it so my point is this these
leftists it all comes down to have not
actually read the letter do not actually
understand what his his goals I agree
with you that they didn't read it but
doesn't change the fact that he has some
legitimate well let's say they're all
wrong right and obviously any leftist
who's going to say realizing Osama Bin
Laden was right about everything is like
Beyond stupid and just it it's insane
obviously forget any of that if your
conclusion from any of that is is that
therefore it's okay to slaughter
innocent people then F you you're a
horrible person you're and you're a
Madman but I think the point is what
should like like not the leftist
interpretation of this but say like the
the Ron Paul interpretation of this
which I think he was completely right
about and the pap panan like I'm talking
about the most right-wing and the most
Libertarian not left-wingers at all and
the point that they would make is that
it's like look there's a the panan quote
that I love which I think nail it always
right is he says terrorism is the price
of Empire and if you don't wish to pay
the cost you must abandon the Empire and
I think what you're dealing with here is
that listen these are a group of people
who have a different way of life than us
and a different belief system than us
and I'm not defending that way of life
or that belief system but when you go
over there and you impose your own
brutal dictators on them you slaughter
their innocent civilians and so but I'm
saying but so that's what I think should
be gained from this
those parts are legitimate Grievances
and my issue
is no one disagrees but well some do my
point is here in this room we get it US
foreign policy has been a disaster
Afghanistan is the latest in a long line
of disasters I think it would be unfair
to say every single thing ever done was
a disaster but boy did the US lose a lot
of wars in the past 70 years lose lose
lose lose lose but for these leftists to
do two things one claim Bin Laden was
right and actually be activists who are
prop Palestine who read it well they're
lying and they manipulating and they're
trying to obfuscate what his actual
goals were and two the other leftists
who are claiming they read it and they
thought he was right they did not read
it
that's don't disagree my point that
bothers me is people who are arguing
that like like Glenn greenwald's tweet
is irksome that is not Bin Laden's
grievance they are they are they are
they are single facts of things that
he's using examples of of how we stop St
him from having Sharia and let me let me
read section three I read you section
one section 3 you are a nation that
permits the production trading and usage
of intoxicants you permit drugs and only
forbid the trade of them even though
your nation is the largest consumer of
them he says uh uh where where's the you
are a nation that permits acts of
immorality and you consider them be
pillars of personal freedom you can to
sink down the abyss from level to level
etc etc he goes on to say uh if I go uh
into the earlier sections you allow
fornication homosexuality gambling and
Usery yeah
when when he's mad about US foreign
policy that's like starting to sound
like Kanye when when when he's mad about
US foreign policy it's not for the
reason the anti-war Americans are I I
don't agree with that Tim if you've read
the whole thing as I have yes you're
right he makes a whole bunch of points
that I I disagree with but he also makes
a ton of points that are totally legit
he says you have aggressed upon my
people for decades after decades he
talks about how how Israel was foed upon
the Arab world and that they they oppos
the UN declaration that made it come to
pass I get it I mean like like yes he
has a bunch of that I disagree with
but then he's got to he's a murderous
he's a murderous psychopath he's also
break he's also raising some grievances
you know what are he saying like I I
compare this to BLM okay the u i I don't
think the US should be going to foreign
countries and doing these things but the
argument that is from the left is
essentially let us do horrifying things
to people slave trade uh uh child
marriage all these awful things that's
what he's saying right so how dare you
stop us from doing so he's wrong and and
the the he's a bad guy I mean that
should that should be the conclusion of
all this but I will say
that my point comes down to leftists on
Tik Tok claiming he was right when his
message is he wants Sharia law so okay
so the leftists are wrong for claiming
that he's wrong for wanting Sharia law
but I just think look let so let's again
those people are wrong but let's just
talk about what's right for a minute and
I'll say this this this is a point that
I tried to make uh in in the debate I
did last night with Laura lomer for Zero
Hedge but she was basically just like
condemning Islam the whole time and
talking about and I was trying to just
just have this moment of being like well
look let's just try to be really fair
here okay so let's try to think this
through and I'm not obviously Bin
Laden's a bad guy but think about what
we did after 9/11 how crazy we went as a
country like in terms of how what we
would support what our government did
what the response to it was that we look
back at this now and we go wait so we
got essentially missil bombed with two
planes and and World Trade Center and we
we created the Department of Homeland
Security and the Patriot Act and the TSA
and the war in Afghanistan and the war
in Iraq which we almost all universally
look back on and go whoa that was wrong
John McCain in his Memoir wrote that the
war in Iraq was a mistake so almost
everybody like acknowledges like we went
a little bit crazy after 911 and did a
whole bunch of bad things a lot of
innocent people died over that now try
to imagine and I want you to really try
to imagine this that 1,000 911s happened
to us and what that would look like how
crazy we would go that's the reality in
the Muslim world now I'm not saying this
Justus any of this and if your takeaway
of this is that Osama Bin Laden is a
good guy you might be an idiot
16-year-old leftist but I'm just saying
that before we sit here and condemn them
for how a and I think this is the point
that Glenn Greenwald is trying to get at
here is that it's like look when what
he's talking about in this letter is
describing a, 911s and if you actually
do the numbers in terms of dead it's
probably more than that but whatever
just imagining that and so if we're
going to sit here and our reaction to
that is going to be like but you're a
radical islamist and all of this is
crazy that you want Sharia law okay fine
and fine but seeing as what our reaction
was just after 1 911 I don't know that
after you know after a, 911s Sheamus
gets in control what do you think he's
going to work be some radical
Christianity based on the letter what
should these leftists do to remedy what
they've done and you know what the
answer is
straight convert to Islam convert to
Islam explicitly says as second question
what are we calling you to do calling
you to Islam the religion of unification
of God Bin Laden attacked us for two
reasons he says because you opposed you
you've obstructed our our the life that
we want the rules that we want he says
specifically your attacks on us include
fornication gambling Usery Etc and what
do we want you to do now join
Islam forication Usery but not alcohol
that's what I'm saying all right okay we
might meet in the middle there uh but do
you think let me ask you this Tim do you
think and I mean this is a real human
terms like trying to put yourself in in
the position of of these people do you
think Osama Bin Laden was able to
recruit people to be willing to Suicide
bomb themselves to death because like do
you think a pretty major factor of that
was that maybe they had seen someone who
they loved started the first J the the
first Jihad I I I don't know well I I I
kind of think if you have I don't know
the first Jihad which is what was it
went on for a thousand plus years and
they went from uh the Middle East all
throughout Europe up to Spain I don't I
don't know was that caused by a thousand
911s was it like oh I
think but I think I think going that far
back in history kind ofs I have I have
to make this point because in the in the
letter itself he says 3,000 of your
people die and all hell breaks loose 1.5
million of our people die
and you won't even you won't even blink
an eye the point that he's making uh
setting aside all of the islamist
all of the all of the leftist
argumentation is that we don't treat
them as if they're real people we treat
them as if they're lesser and that's
true well and and and until until we're
willing to accept that reality and
actually like look in the mirror if I
was born in Gaza in
2006 I would be of fighting age today
and I would have never had any
sovereignty whatsoever I'm ruled by
Hamas I'm ruled by the IDF if I go too
close to the Border I get shot I would
be a complete lunatic anytime you bring
this up people say oh you're trying to
you're trying to justify terrorism
you're trying to you know make it sound
as if Hamas is the good guys I'm not
doing that what I'm doing is I'm putting
myself in the shoes of people that have
been legitimately oppressed and I'm not
talking about the critical theory
oppression I'm talking about real effing
oppression where your whole life has
been dominant let me ask you a question
why were the Marines formed the bar and
and what did what what did the sultan
say to Thomas Jefferson which require
resulted in him saying you know what
fine then we're forming the Marines but
the the well the Pirates were Bri or uh
demanding uh R when when when the
American ships were being attacked by
the North African Barber States
Jefferson and Adams many other uh us uh
agents were like yo we got no problem
with you guys why are you consistently
attacking our ships and you know what
the response was our religion said were
allowed to do it yeah yeah okay he said
if that's what you're going to do I am
going to raise a navy and I will wipe
you out and it was probably a big
mistake by the way English Empire Ser I
mean think about the implications of
first off he didn't get a declaration of
war from Congress he just went about it
with having Thomas Mark Mark and
reprisal that was that was the the point
no no no they got kind of it wasn't even
Mark and reprisal it was kind of like
almost an authorization of military
force type deal by the way the French
and the British had forever just been
paying those pirates off paying their
Ransom and I think he ended up spending
a lot more money on it than if he had
just paid them off so people died and he
wasted a lot of money I'm not saying
it's the right thing to do the Pirates
were the aggressors in that but here's
my issue with this my issue with when we
go back to like okay but look in the
year uh
1801 a radical Muslim did this or that
here's kind of the problem that look
there uh do you guys familiar with the
uh King crane commission no okay so the
king crane commission was uh after World
War I uh the end of World War I I think
it started at the Paris peace conference
and they were trying to get the British
and the French on board but they kind of
pulled out of it so the Americans just
did it without him but they sent a
commission into uh the Muslim world
because the Ottoman Empire had collapsed
and now there were all these territories
that used to be ruled by the Ottoman
Empire and they were kind of going on
like a fact-f finding Mission like they
went there to just kind of like survey
and interview a lot of people and figure
out what we're going to do with this
part of the world and there's a few
really interesting things that they
found number one uh Syria overwhelmingly
voted and Syria back then was much
bigger than Syria today but so it's like
the land Syria is and then I think a
bigger area than that overwhelmingly
they said who would you like to to rule
you under a League of Nations mandate
and overwhelmingly Syria voted for the
United States of America so it this
narrative that they hate us because
we're free is really not very true in
fact when we were viewed as the ones who
weren't the imperialist force remember
this is World War I okay they they were
like America the city on the hill that's
all about freedom and doesn't intervene
in our part of the world we love those
guys like they had nothing but a
positive feeling about those guys and
likewise early on if you read the early
Zionist writers they were not like they
didn't consider the Arabs to be an enemy
so my my point is just that actually a
lot of I'm not saying every the problem
with when you go back to say like the
seventh century or you go back hundreds
and hundreds of years and go look they
were being barbaric then the truth is
that everyone was being barbaric then if
we if we look at more recent and more
relevant history you realize that
actually there a lot of this the syrians
had no problem with America they hated
the British and the French why is that
social media algorithms are resulting in
people sharing things they don't
understand and I don't I agree with you
on that and what I am bothered by is
seeing people I can use the specific
example of Glenn Greenwald instead of
pointing out what's going on
misrepresenting the summation of what
Bin Laden wrote for the justification of
their ideology I don't think he's
misrepresenting it I think he literally
is well no I think he's trying to point
out what he views as the most important
aspect of that and I think maybe you're
pointing out what you view as the most
important aspect of that I think I'll
tell you I'm pointing out the letter has
two questions the first one is 5050
between the prevention of sharia law and
allowing of homosexuality along with
foreign policy from the United States
and the second part is that the US is
not Islamic if you're going to claim his
three grievances are us specific US
foreign policy actions you are
misrepresenting what been he also says
that he was but he did mention all of
those specific grievances that Glen
Greenwald laid out so my guess would be
and maybe this is a more charitable
interpretation but I think that what
Glenn Greenwald is saying is essentially
that like kind of my position on this
that well obviously it's a given that
Osama Bin Laden's a bad guy and an
islamist like no one's I mean I guess
some crazy 16-year-olds are but no
normal person is really questioning
that look at and now let me clarify for
you again if Bin Laden says I attacked
you because of these things and Glenn
says actually it was these things that's
misrepresentation but he does mention
those he does say those things if Bin
Laden says there are two main
points okay the first being the attacks
on us which includes physical and
ideological okay and the second half of
is you must become Muslim and then and
then Glen goes actually it was only
about US foreign policy he say he three
points and he names three specific for
I'll tell you what bothers me what
bothers me is when activists with policy
ends lie to gain power but it's not it's
not a lie as much as you're saying he
left out part of it he mentioned three
things explicitly States in his tweet
that his his three main grievances are
so he claims those are the main
Grievances and they're not there's two
main grievances one is the attack on
them and their ideology both physical
and ideological and the second is that
we must convert to Islam so when people
say they hate us for our freedoms I
think it's stupid and oversimplified you
could say well look and you're saying
this is stupid and over over when when
we engage in Foreign Wars which destroy
the way of life of people who don't want
to live the way we do we're making
enemies and what they want is for us to
convert to their way of life if if if
the United States foreign policy acted
in ways that resulted in the benefit of
Islam Bin Laden would have been happy
and he would have wrote that see here's
the issue though possibly up until up
until there was decades of interference
into the Middle East they weren't
actually trying to get us to convert it
like yes his letter this aspect of his
letter obviously I reject it and I'm not
going to become a Muslim to acques to
Osama bin Lan's demands yeah you you'll
be relieved to know he's dead yes thank
goodness uh but but all I'm taking away
from this letter is is what aligns with
with reality and what does align with
reality is that we have bombed his
people for decades and he does
categorize that he says the sanction
regime in Iraq you guys don't care about
this he says we have tried to be civil
we have tried to rationalize with I
pointed that out I agree the point is
but that matters that's important to
talk about broken into two sections you
have physically and ideologically
attacked us and you won't convert let me
read another section for you this is
section 2A of his second half of his
letter we call you to be people of
manners principles honor and Purity to
reject the immoral acts of fornication
homosexuality intoxicant gambling and
trading with interest to say his main
grievances are specifically US foreign
policy is wrong is he mad about us there
were many other speeches and many other
letters that he get where he he
mentioned these grievances over and over
so you're right again he's a radical
islamist like yeah like I don't know why
why are
people I'm I'm I'm going to lay it
plainly I am sick of ideologues
manipulating information for their
personal ideological ends but you're
making it sound as if it's not actually
listed it he does no I agree it is
listed there's two sections the
ideological and physical attacks as well
as we not converting to Islam ISL those
are the two main what I'm what I'm
taking from it is what do I have control
over I'm not going to become a radical
islamist I'm not going to adapt Sharia
law what I can do is get my effing State
Department to
stop just explain kind of why I I
disagree with you the question is simply
this would Osama Bin Laden is are you
arguing that he only attacked us because
of US foreign policy
I think he would not have I don't think
he would have had the capacity to attack
us if not for the radicalization that
Happ our sanction he was a psychopath I
think the reason he was able to recruit
enough people who were willing to commit
suicide and attacking us was probably
blowback but let me say this this I
think is essentially my disagreement
with you and like you use the kind of
black lives matter Michael Brown analogy
I'd look at it kind of like if you were
let's say you were trapping someone in
your basement and torturing them every
every single day and they are they went
crazy and completely lost their mind and
wrote some Manifesto and half of the
manifesto was like just the rantings of
a Madman and half of it was like and you
came down here and you beat me with a
wire every single day and that's why I'm
going to try to kill you and then that
guy came and killed you I'd go well yeah
I mean look at the manifesto he came and
killed you because you were torturing
him every day whereas someone else could
look at that and go no these are the ran
things of a mad
man
no it's not perect it's not a perect
analogy but the Mike Brown analogy isn't
a Perfect Analogy either I'm just saying
that is I think's try to get my point
with Mike Brown is specifically for the
leftists who are adopting this and
claiming he's right when yeah well
they're stupid and then when when people
like Glenn come out and say well Bin
Laden was mad about war this fuels the
indoctrination of moronic Millennials
and you keep saying 16y olds but dude
these are millennials who are in their
30s no I know they're still 16 but I get
your point they're very old and they're
running for office and they're in office
and they're and they're chanting these
things in the streets they're in New
York celebrating I get your point on
that I'm just saying that also I mean
Glenn Greenwald has like been serving
them a heavy dose of reality through all
of this crize where I think he need to
fair enough fair enough but I'm also
saying that I don't technically think he
said anything wrong if you want to say
he omitted the fact that Osama Bin Laden
is also a radical islamist I would just
be charitable and say like I think
that's a given for saying people even
for these people that you're pulling up
so fair enough anyone who read Glen
greenwald's tweet would have a would
have a an incorrect interpretation of
the of the summation of the letter I
think I think if they only heard your
interpretation they'd have an incorrect
summation too I I gave you the two full
points and and and gave you the there's
a lot that's included in there the the
sanction regime you didn't mention that
was 1.5 million he says you killed we
killed 3,000 of yours all of a sudden
you care the whole reason they the
physical attacks on their countries but
deta because he's saying he's saying I
have tried to have civil conversation
you all don't listen to us you only
respond to aggression we're going to
give you aggression I'm not justifying
any of this and there is a in section
one if I'm not mistaken cuz I I didn't
get a chance to read this today when we
found it because it's been scrubbed from
the Internet it's been years since I've
read this and so I'm going off memory
but I did think in section one he did
list out those three grievances right
like I understand there were the two
sections but I think he did list out the
three grievances of like military bases
in Saudi Arabia
the first grievance is the first
Palestine is is the first grievance is
Palestine so for Glenn to say it's Iraq
and it's is Israel and then Saudi land
when actually the first point was it
should be Israel then Iraq then sa so
it's it's Israel it is Israel it is
Israel it is Israel okay then it's
Somalia uh number five is Somalia then
it's uh uh the next section goes on to
be like you guys use violence to prevent
Sharia everywhere but he doesn't talk
about a global caliphate he's not
talking no I know but but the point
you're bringing up with these specific
things I'm not there yet I'm in section
uh seven not there yet eight not there
yet nine Palestine still uh 10 uh still
not there still we want Sharia law and
you're blocking Sharia the next one is
uh okay you're stealing our oil and it's
the biggest theft in mankind okay still
not those specific military things but
yes generally foreign policy here we go
finally I think we're at Point 13 you
occupy our countries with military bases
allow Jew SK you're skipping over number
one after like paragraph two where he
says because you attacked us and
continued to attack us and then he says
a you attacked us in Palestine and then
he starts how many times do I got to say
the first section is that we attack them
well I know but you're saying say that
you're saying he doesn't do it until the
very end that's not true it in the very
the point that Glenn Greenwald made have
not even come up after the 15 say you're
saying that uh the the Iraq blockade
didn't come up until much later in I'm
saying that for Glenn to make these
points that these are the main
grievances is Glenn choosing subjects
that benefit his ideology and it's
manipulative and I I am sick of
ideologues who do this I don't care if
you're the Left Right libertarian up
down whatever I don't care if you're
Christian Muslim whatever if you're
going to lie to me to steal power I'm
going to call you out for it well I
don't think Glenn Greenwald is trying to
steal any power he's trying to impose
his ideologically ideological values by
obusca what's actually being said he has
his own bias when he reads this he takes
away certain you know notes that he
thinks that that's the yeah can we sayen
screw Glenn Greenwald and let's talk
talk about the substance of this letter
for a little bit my point is just using
him as a singular example the left is
arguing that Bin Laden is right because
the first 15 paragraphs are almost
entirely about Palestine and and the
context is Israel and Palestine are
currently in a the hottest conflict
we've seen in our lifetimes and so they
are deciding to claim all of his stuff
about Sharia and Islam is also correct
in its enti well look I mean look again
I think you can say this and I know
there's a tendency for people to kind of
caricature what characterize what you
say but uh why is it that this is
there's fertile ground for even this
type of craziness to take off right now
and it is because well look there's this
war in Gaza going on right now which is
pretty horrific and a lot of like
innocent people are dying in that war
and so even when you have this letter
that's talking all about how those
people over there hate you in large part
because of what your government has
propped up Israel to be able to do in
Gaza this is probably at least partially
why there's fertile ground for this
narrative to catch fire right now not
that doesn't mean it's completely right
no it's it's actually not right but the
here's the problem is that we lied to
the American people not we but the
government did they didn't tell
us the truth about why they were
actually upset with us so now you have
all of these kids that are growing up
going like they hate us because we're
free and then they realize oh it's
actually not just that it's actually not
cuz it's not true and it hasn't been
true from the beginning so so because
they were received now they go to Tik
Tok to learn history lessons and then
they get misled and we're all upset
about it well haven't we just start by
telling the truth is social media is
indoctrinating young people the
Millennials and lower into psychotic
beliefs this kid I pointed up did not
just say we were lied to he says Bin
Laden was right okay now that's
stupid but here's the really sad thing
Tim even though you're right and that is
insane they're getting better history
than George W bush taught them so as as
crazy as all of this is at least now
they're hearing the other side of the
story they're still reaching a very dumb
conclusion if their conclusion is Osama
Bin Laden was right not read the letter
okay I I don't know there's no way of
knowing that for sure there's no there's
no reasonable way to say that a leftist
agrees with the statement that we must
ban homosexuality yeah I agree I agree
with you here's why I I think you're
you're wrong in a sense because the
leftists will be so hypocritical that
almost every situation they at they have
to look at it through who is the
oppressor versus who is the oppressed
and whoever is the more white European
looking ones is always the more and if
those two things completely contradict
each other it doesn't
matter in general if a Muslim is being
oppressed then they'll be like okay
we're on the side of the Muslim and then
if they feel like a gay person's being
oppressed they're on the side of the gay
person and the fact that that Muslim and
that gay person would not get along very
well does not like register age with but
it's more mostly about ignorance like
when they have queers for Palestine and
they made the pride Palestine flag
there's a big difference between not
knowing anything and just waving a flag
and reading a direct statement that says
abandon and
ban woke up and was like gez it's 8:30
a.m. well Osama Bin Laden was right that
doesn't mean that he's right about
everything he said probably some things
in here are correct it's specifically
about why they were attacking he seems
pretty honest the Palestine stuff but
then we got to be clear he didn't say
that they're fighting us because we
won't adopt Sharia part of is you won't
let us practice our Sharia in our
countries of choice so we will fight
then the part of the second part what
are we calling on you to do now is like
adopt Sharia they're pissed they're
beyond the pale at that point yes
because he says you guys have aggressed
so so consistently and you don't listen
to reason you don't listen to rational
discussion you don't want to have any
negotiations you want to be you don't
want to be civil at all think about this
we we phrase these radical jihadis as
the most unil barbaric people on the
planet they look at us the Americans and
they say yo all aren't civil think about
how crazy that is the head choppers in
Syria think that the American Empire
isn't civil people need to internalize
this actually think about what they're
saying there that's profound that's
profound that they think that we are The
Barbarians on Earth T like take it in
for a second for real well you know this
is something that I kind of like came
across in in the debate I was doing last
night and there's part of this uh thing
where PE look we are
unquestionably say the United States of
America and and Israel uh compared to
the Muslim World in which we've fought a
lot of Wars over the last couple decades
we are undeniably much more advanced
much more sophisticated uh much more
systematized and they are much more
primitive than us and so it's very easy
for people to go like you know what
people who are on say like the
pro-israeli side of the the argument if
you go well look I mean Hamas killed all
these people I think that that's really
wrong what happened on October 7th but
then look Israel's killing all these
innocent people in response and I think
that's wrong it's very easy for them to
be like no no no no no that was
barbarians targeting civilians and this
is Collateral Damage Done by military
strikes and it's very easy in the
Western World to feel this difference
that like well that no but that's just
different you know what I mean this is
kind of like look this is bad
policy or even good policy that happens
to have these negative you know uh um
results but if those are your kids and
your sisters and your mothers and your
wives who are dying as a result of that
policy it is very easy to say that is
every bit as barbaric that is every bit
as evil as whatever you know what I mean
like could be done in return well it's
even more brutal because you're coming
from a very poor place like the people
in Gaza are so destitute you have a full
sanction regime all they've dealt with
is bombardment year aftere sniper fire
these people have been radicalized and
we and we refuse to just look in the
damn mirror and say why thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net